Vaness is with us in New York - Nessa
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for having your show all these
years well it didn't help
thank you mom so I'm calling because I'm
about to be divorced and I have a nine
month old son which prompted me to
switch careers or think about switching
careers are adding to my income but I'm
currently teaching I've been teaching
for 15 years I still only make fifty
nine thousand in the New York City area
and I would like to go into nursing
maybe really I would just want to clean
up my bed to be honest with you but
nursing I think would be a good fit for
me
he's a pacified hustle my debt is 120
2000s undergrad and grad I can go
through and accelerated BSN program for
my bachelor's in nursing and I could
finish it in a year or I could do that
right right I mean within a couple years
I I can take a sabbatical from work
which would give me half pay for a year
so with that sabbatical I could go to
nursing school with scholarships I will
never take a loan ever again I can go to
nursing school or I can go overseas and
teach and make up to $100,000 go teach
in Hong Kong or in parts of the Middle
East so I'm just trying to figure out
what to do
it's how long were you married 11 years
okay so what I don't want you to do is
make either one of these decisions based
on some kind of fear like this divorce
this divorce isn't knocked you on your
heels a little bit if it didn't you
wouldn't be a human being most human
beings have feelings and and and
something like this hurts your feelings
to say the least that would be an
understatement
and so the I sense a little bit and I
may be wrong maybe you're just make are
you flailing a little bit um well I
planned on going overseas my
soon-to-be-ex-husband was okay with me
taking the baby the match has been I
understand this doesn't sound like it's
my life's plan it sounds like the way
your dispute it's like I could do this
or I could do that I could do this and
it's kind of like it's kind of like you
need you like you feel like you need to
get a hold of something real quick or
it's gonna go bad or something
no I talk overseas before I lived in
Japan for Sean what do you do with your
life no I wanna Bieber raise my son and
be debt-free your career let's say you
were debt-free and you were raising your
son let's just to put that as a let's
stipulate that okay that's done okay
because you're gonna do that I'm gonna
show you how to do that
all right now so you're raising your son
and your debt-free do you want to be a
nurse do you want to be teaching
overseas do you want to be a something
else what do you want to be 10 years
from now you're sighs I want to be
traveling with my son when teaching
overseas is the way yeah traveling with
my son doing mission trips there and
they're throwing him the world still
haven't answered my question
how old are you I'm 30 38 I'm gonna be
39 so when you're 50 years old and
you're looking back and you go man after
that divorce I made some really good
choices that led me to where I am now in
my career I'm really glad I do that
because I get to go to work every day
and make money and do something that
causes me to smile what does that look
like nothing really see you see that is
fulfilling not just a money grab to get
out of debt to be able to travel the
world no I see as fulfilling because my
mom didn't have the education she was a
nurse's aide and she didn't before she
passed away I'm four and a half years I
mean three and a half years ago she
didn't have she was a nurse's aide and
she didn't have the education to do it
my sister doesn't have the education to
do it and I feel
I'd be carrying on a legacy and I think
they'd be I mean they're already proud
of me but I think they'd be extra proud
of me and icing on the cake is that you
can make really good money and I can be
a travel nurse I can do all those things
together and caring is a part of what I
do with teaching folks but to be honest
you know that's now we're getting into
teaching fields is crazy it's just
getting worse well yeah I don't about
that I mean it's not the kids it's the
parents or the like no I love my
students not the parents it's just that
this here the helicopter is coming in
there my parents are awesome my students
are great I love teaching but the
paperwork and just what is the testing
is just too much and I don't want to do
that anymore I understand all right
well then take the steps that are the
shortest path to get to be the 50 year
old you that we just described now is
that going overseas to teach for a year
so we can easily pay cash and get
through nursing or is it let's just bust
into the nursing take the half pay and
are you can you and you can live on the
half pay while you do that you can make
it yes because I don't pay rent I live
in my mom wait okay all right so you can
live there for a year take half pay live
on that finish the nursing and that's
the shortest distance to the nursing
getting it yes it is and that's where
you want to go it is where I want to go
now that you really like press me yeah
so they're touching overseas a detour
it's the wrong direction yeah you're
right you're gonna finish the nursing
and you're gonna nurse overseas so you
get to travel with your son and see
things and make really good money as a
nurse because you love the adventure of
travel combined with being a nurse my
hair my sir
did I hear you're right yes are you when
you hit the nail on the head sir okay
all right you rock this girl you're
gonna be great thank you so much the
next chapter is gonna be really pretty
it's gonna be beautiful
don't do it on purpose okay yes sir I
got a copy of Ken Coleman's book for you
the proximity principle because it fits
in with everything we're just talking
about here all I did was walk you down
the same process Ken does on his show
every day
I stole it from him I listen to him all
the time the proximity principle the
proven strategy that will lead to the
career you love here what we just did
yeah he does this all the time he's
really good at it it's it's fun to
listen to but all we doing is doing
stuff intentionally with a long-term
game plan in mind people if you'd do
that it with different portions of your
life different segments of your life
it'll change your life
so hang on miss Vanessa we'll get you a
copy of that book
[Music]